hey gang I'm Mark Ellis and it is time
to drop the puck on a new show down here
this week we're gonna see who's the
bigger action star Sylvester or Arnold
we're about to find out
welcome to the party pal I'm the party
pooper you're gonna fight are you plan
on boring me to death why not have a
little bit of duking out and here's how
it works
round 1 box-office round number 2 tomato
bleeder
round 3 action sequences who has the
best ones ding the bell because we're
about to talk box office the stats here
can favor either contestant Stallone has
more movies but for the overall lifetime
box-office achievement that actually
goes to Sylvester Stallone and it ain't
that close he's got four point nine
billion dollars in movie tickets while
Arnold Schwarzenegger still a very
respectable 3.7 billion dollars however
the average box-office of each one of
their movies Arnold beets sly slightly
124 million dollars to sli's 118 million
dollars six million dollars is the
difference that's pocket change doesn't
it feel like for two guys who can both
benchpress North Dakota that Arnold does
more of the heavy lifting it's his name
that stands out poses above all I'm
supposed to be scared his face is bigger
on the posters he's the singular hero of
his movies more often
Stallone maybe the better writer actor
certainly better director I loved
Schwarzenegger even knows there's a
camera on his phone if I have to open
any action flick with one action star
I'm taking Arnie all day long
hasta LaVista baby I'm taking Arne
because I went to go see Terminator 2 I
was 11 years old and snuck in and then
my mom found out I got grounded for two
weeks
that was Judgment Day am I crazy
do you take sly or do you take Arnie how
about we all take a look at the actual
quality of the film this is where we
rely on the ever trusty tomato meter
let's start with the Honorable mr.
Schwarzenegger his highest film
according to the tomato meter is the
Terminator the original one from 1984
it's a hundred percent on Rotten
Tomatoes his lowest rated major movie
Batman and Robin alright everyone chill
ten percent that is very very cold
I think twins Kindergarten Cop they make
Oscar
and stop her my mom will shoot look even
worse it's not a tuma I've just been
told that's not possible those movies
cannot possibly look any worse on the
other side of the ledger Sylvester
Stallone is still making great content
his highest film on the tomato meter
2015 s Creed 95% his lowest rated major
movie the specialist at 7% where have
you gone
James Woods also fun fact he directed
stayin alive
yeah that's zero percent on the tomato
meter plus Stallone helped usher in the
era of the aging action star still doing
it he gets a gang together and he makes
us all feel like we're kids again at the
box office what happened to you kid that
actually even helped Arnold
Schwarzenegger stay relevant when he was
doing his post governor comeback
yes member only when he was the Governor
of California uh anyway so how about the
averages Arnold Schwarzenegger is
narrowly defeating sly in the average
tomato meter artis is 46.1% sly just
below him at 44% how are neither one of
these guys averaging mid-90s their films
are all-time greats
[Music]
uh anyway so I gets my vote but it's up
to you I'm busy anyway so give this chop
to my friend who he loves playing in the
jungle right battles this is what we
want from sly and from our need not sure
rocky had to go the distance against
some of the best boxers of his era
and Rambo had to take on everything from
a local police force to resistance
fighters and blonds Wesley Snipes at one
point but on torts negger he fought
satan like he literally fought satan you
can watch a boxer and learn how they bob
and weave i don't know if you can watch
The Exorcist and be like oh there's
Beelzebub's weakness I know how to fight
the devil but Schwarzenegger did it and
won not to mention we took on an alien
he went to Mars and he fought people who
have more breasts than usually we do
here on earth
[Music]
summer screaming hey wait a minute
so let's do a tiebreaker the Carl
Weathers factor which should be a
reality show if it's not already let's
see what happens when each of our stars
went up against action Jackson
so Stallone fought him in the ring three
times he lost one he won one and then
they had a match just in private just
for them and we don't really know who
won but Stallone did hint in the first
Creed that he lost that fight to Apollo
who won the third fight he did so he's
one and two against Carl Weathers
meanwhile Arnold easily defeated Carl
Weathers when they did that
chummy handshake turned greeting turn
armwrestling match at the beginning a
predator I guess that's how real men
greet each other what's the matter
the CIA got to pushing too many pencils
I'll survive predator Carl Weathers
spoilered did not so maybe Dutch should
have recruited Ivan Drago instead too
soon
sorry - the Creed family the wild card
round we're gonna throw in something
crazy and for Arnold and sly it's got to
be one liners oh this is too close to
call they're just so good at delivering
such bad lines come with me if you want
to live
[Music]
my mobile shoots so maybe we do this
let's try to imagine how each star would
do with their counterparts rivalries I'm
your worst nightmare
yo Adrian I did it or how about
Sylvester Stallone garbling out such
phrases as good to the jaw I'll be back
I was totally here by the crew that my
Arnold and sly impersonations are
perfectly not good thanks to all the
support I get here Rotten Tomatoes but
at the end of the day after looking at
all the facts and all the stats I'm
gonna go with Arnold Schwarzenegger
Arnold gets the win or at least he gets
my vote for the win I'm just one vote
now it's up to y'all you can go in the
comments section and simply just say who
you think won or do you agree with me
did I make a killer argue of course I
made a killer argument but do you think
it's also Arnold then type Arnold
because Schwarzenegger is really hard to
spell or if you think Stallone won just
type slide type Sylvester type rocky
Rambo we're gonna disseminate it here
Rotten Tomatoes and determine a winner
that you can tune in to next episode to
find out so we'll have the winner of
that and we'll have a brand new matchup
for you how do we determine that I don't
know apparently you guys are gonna do
that too
so comment and let us know what mashup
do you want to see
should it be two more action stars going
head to head should it be two romantic
comedy stars stepped on Hanks and Ryan
Gosling Duke it I'd pay good money to
see it okay well I gotta say bye because
the bus is leaving I'm Mark Ellis thanks
for tuning into I really have to sign
off this alright hasta LaVista baby
you